[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please welcome the
newlyweds mr and mrs simon doyle
you must meet archul puero my
congratulations madame
but he's only the greatest detective
alive
i suspect you invited me for reasons
other than the fun
you had something so high we have the
karnak all to ourselves a chef and
enough champagne to fill the nile
[Music]
when you have money no one is ever
really your friend
it's too late to change events it's time
to face the concept
someone is dead
[Music]
the crime
is murder
ever again is what the murderer
is one of you
were you aware of any grudges madam is
used to getting what she wants
never again
i don't feel safe
i don't feel safe with any of that
there are so many conflicting hates and
jealousies
oh i like this did you see or hear
anything
i did not trust her i still don't what
did you do last night you accused me of
murder
he accuses everyone of murder it is a
problem i
admit i was methodically
[Music]
blind i not trust you what do you want
me to say
[Music]
someone else is dead
lying my face lock the doors
the murderer is here and we'll stay here
[Music]
[Music]
you